But I think politically it makes sense for Jeff to endorse number
one.
>> Politically it makes sense. Wait, that's >> okay.
He's gaslighting. >> So Pisco Pisco totally won that conversation
then. >> Totally. But >> he doesn't know where he's
going. Okay. >> Which one is it? >> He's just He's
just on a journey. Okay. This is why I don't >> Hutch doesn't
know Hutch's mind. Listen, in his mind where he's going, >> it's
a dark place. He doesn't have a flashlight. He is stumbling around.
Okay. He's trying to figure out. He doesn't know. Okay. He doesn't
know the recesses of his own mind. They shouldn't be able to
make it divisive. You have a Democrat who won the primary. How
do you How do you let them make this divisive? Just endorse them.
Endorse the candidate for your party. Actually look at their
positions. Tell me what's wrong with them that you would not
endorse them.
If you guys weren't here last night, we covered Hutch versus
Pisco at the end of Live and Learn. Okay? And you know, you're
my boy, Hutch. It seems like, >> oh my god, what's Hutch
doing? >> It seems like we have uh Hutch, it was brought
up today. Okay. Some people decided to bring up this whole thing
today in his chat. >> We're going to check this out cuz
I'm I'm very interested to know. >> How is he hanging in
there? >> Yeah. How is he doing? >> Call Pisco. He's
crying. Me and Pisco went at it the fridge. >> I just >> Wait,
I just pulled way back from my time stamp and it didn't go far
enough. his mind would just go to like he was >> I I went
to back up a little bit and I didn't back up anywhere near far
enough. So here's here's like the starting point. I'll be give
me two seconds. I'll be right back. >> He was always trying
to sniff out a lie even when I was telling the truth. And so
you you kind of get I don't know if it's gaslighting but you
you know he was so persistent in his interrogations
that I would even question myself like wait am I lying? Did I
do this? Um
>> he was just really intense. if there was something that
was out of place,
you know, or somebody ate too many of his Oreos. He had like
a big jar of Oreos. It was like his Oreo jar and he put it on
the top of the fridge >> so that we we we couldn't get
to it, but then I would just get on the stool and take his Oreos.
And then one time I fell off the stool and comp did a compound
fracture on my arm, >> which was gnarly. >> Have
you been listening to this? >> Yeah, I think Hutch is about
to compare his dad to Pisco. He's saying that Pisco he just Pisco
kept uh grilling him if he ever felt like something was wrong
or Hutch lied. He kept grilling him and he felt gas lit by that.
>> But hold on. I actually don't know. I think he's referring
to a family member right now. And that might be what leads
>> He's talking about his dad like clearly. >> Okay.
But before we get there, can we wrap our head around the idea
that hey, if someone is holding me to my words and wants me to
remain principled, that's kind of gaslighting.
>> I Okay. Yes. >> It's like someone stole his Oreo
cookies. Like what? >> I'm finding I'm finding it much
more insane that a conversation about his dad being like persistent
and holding him to his word turned into, "Oh yeah, Pisco's like
that, too. Pisco's like my dad." is like just the weirdest progression
that this must be going through because where I where I hit play
it seemed like he was talking about Pisco and I didn't realize
until he started talking about the cookie jar that he's actually
talking about a family member. >> Pisco has a reason for
why he's asking the questions he's asking. He kind of knows where
it's going to end up. That's a lawyer. A lawyer is not going
to ask questions he doesn't know the answer to. >> Kind
of thing. A cop >> is going to test you. He's going to
ask you questions to see what you're going to say. He's like
testing the waters. Not testing the waters. He's fishing. He's
looking.
>> Uh, yeah. >> He's got a gut feeling.
>> Pisco is going off of a history of what you've said
and what you've claimed to have stood for. >> Not the same
at all. But I'm I'm interested. I'm interested >> and smug.
Like if somebody asks you, "What's your biggest weakness?" And
then you then you say like, "I'm too honest." Okay. It's going
to sound like that a little bit, but I'm a horrible liar. I am
a horrible liar. You know what that comes from? That comes from
being raised by a cop. That's what that comes from.
>> Good luck lying to my father. He would break me. Like
he would mentally break
>> I didn't do that. I I don't know. I didn't do that.
And then like 5 minutes later, I'm like crying. >> Okay.
But it sounds like >> even though you're horrible, you
would still lie. >> Even though he was horrible at lying,
he would still lie. >> Oh, yeah. Sure, sure, sure. >> So,
you know what? Now that I think about it, you know what? It might
have made me a better liar because I was forged in the fire of
like police
Um, you know, there were sometimes I got away with lies when
I was a kid. There were sometimes. And I have to pat my back
on the myself on the back, but but it's hard. Like I like I It's
hard. I had um I have like an internal like intense internal
response if I'm lying. You guys saw me playing Among Us. Yeah,
exactly. That is the best example. You guys saw me playing Among
Us. I would break before they even really put any kind of meaningful
pressure on me. Like Nanners would ask me just a really simple
question and I would just break. I'd be like, "I'm uh I don't
know. I don't know, bro. I don't know." And Nanners would be
like, "What do you >> Was Nanners like your cop dad? Is
that what he's giving me whiplash?
>> Uh-huh. I He just admitted, "Oh, well, maybe that's
actually what makes me a really good liar." And then he just
went back to, "Oh, but remember Among Us, I was such a bad liar."
>> He doesn't know where he's going. Okay, which one is
it? >> He's just He's just on a journey. Okay. Hutch doesn't
know. Hutch's mind. >> Listen, in his mind, he doesn't
know where he's going. >> It's a dark place. He doesn't
have a flashlight. He is stumbling around, okay? He's trying
to figure out. He doesn't know, okay? He doesn't know the recesses
of his own mind. >> This is like that uh that question
I asked AI.
Can I trust a an ex addict felon or convict? >> Can I trust
a convict who used to be addicted to heroin? >> And it
it told you not to trust unless they give you like reasons to
to trust them essentially.
>> Are you saying
are you applying that to Hutch right now? >> Can't trust
him unless he gives you a
>> Yes. I think for I'm going to automatically believe
that Hutch is lying to me. >> Okay. All right. Wait, where
where were you just like 5 seconds ago? I I was
um you know how good are cops at catching lies? The thing is
like with my dad, he was just eternally suspicious. So even when
I was telling the truth, his mind would just go to like he was
always he was always trying to sniff out a lie even when I was
telling the truth. >> and so you you kind of get I don't
know if it's gaslighting, but you know, he was so persistent
in his interrogations.
>> I don't know if it's gaslighting,
dude. I think the next thing he says is, "Oh, sometimes he would
convince me I was >> That I would even question >> Hutch.
Hutch didn't know what he thought back then either. >> myself
like, "Wait, am I lying? Did I do this?" Um, he was just really
intense. If there was something that was out of place, you know,
or somebody ate too many of his Oreos. He had like a big jar
of Oreos. >> Oh, yeah. This is his >> It was like
his Oreo jar. And he put it on the top of the fridge so that
we we we couldn't get to it. But then I would just get on the
stool and take his Oreos. And then one time I fell off the stool
and did a compound fracture on my arm which was gnarly. Call
Pisco. He's crying. Would never go
>> for Oreos. >> Well, I think he didn't mean to
fall. He was probably just going up on the stool to get the Oreos
and then he fell over and broke his his arm.
>> Yeah. Then somebody says, "Call Hutch would never go
sussy baka mode on us." Right, chat? Hutch, call Pisco. He's
crying. Okay. >> I love Mode. >> Um, call Pisco.
He's crying. Me and Pisco went at it last night. Felt like he
was being a little bit of a debate, bro, to be honest with you.
What's going on with Pisco? Is he even live right
>> I don't even see him.
>> Pisco could be a bit of a debate, bro. Maybe a little
bit. >> Hutch literally advertises himself as an aggressive
liberal. He is a debate bro on Twitter, all over Twitter
>> sometimes. Yeah. I don't know.
I think he's just not very good at it is my issue. That doesn't
make him less of a debate, bro. >> I've seen him have like
contentious conversations like three times and one of them was
against Vim on No Sleep. Okay. He's just not very good at it
is basically all I've observed.
>> So, you we could say he's a debate bro or he's trying
to be. He's like a wannabe debate bro or something. >> He's
not really there.
>> I see him like Ethan Klein. I think he's been convinced
that this is how you should do politics online. Yeah, I he could
you could compare him to Ethan Klein. I just think it's funny
because I know Pisco is the actual debate bro and when I watch
them argue he's not he's like a lesser version. Okay. >> I
just can't I can't really compare the >> Maybe we can watch
some of that argument a little bit a little bit later. Let's
try to get through those. >> But after they explained and
they didn't really explain to him because he was not capable
really of understanding. But when they went out and talked about
it, they acted like it was a great feat by but had nothing to
do with him. Then it continues and
>> we'll get it down even further. But >> look, man,
Pisco is cool, but I think it uh I think he baited it. He baited
into the whole Mandani thing. Madani thing. Pisco knows no peace.
>> Insulin was the people weren't taking it. I would imagine
they just they couldn't take God bless you, Bobby. I hope I didn't
catch co just there. >> Pisco was way too hot last night
with his takes and the way he jumped on you and soy pills
love it. What is it? And the chat's going to fire him up until
the point he's like, "You know what? Pisco was mean to me. Pisco
was too much." Oh my
>> What did Soy Pel even do of use on that on that panel?
>> I have no idea. What did Soy I can't even remember what
Soy Pill's opinion was. Um yeah, I I actually don't >> How
can I offiscate to give Hutch a moment to breathe? >> I
don't even know. Maybe that's what he was doing. I legitimately
cannot remember his contribution in any way. I I like actually
I can remember that conversation quite well. I cannot remember
soy pills speaking. I remember feeling vaguely annoyed, but like
I
>> he's got pax.
>> Give me give me a patch of it >> Pelosi is um
ignoring what you're doing for the American people. She's going
after your administration for cutting
>> Hold on. I'm just looking. He absolutely was. He needs
to calm the down when arguing with his boys. Pelosi is ignoring
what you're doing for
>> if you were actually his boy he wouldn't treat you like
that. Okay. >> American people. She's going after your
administration for cutting taxpayer funed healthcare for illegal
aliens last night. Nancy Pelosi. She went on NBC last night.
Dropped a bunch of f bombs. Told Republic. >> My thing
with Pisco last night was like so we >> I told I knew it.
I knew they were going to get him like fired up. You know what?
Pisco Pisco was actually rude. That's actually true. Pisco really
was rude, wasn't he? >> In case you missed I assume many
of you guys missed it. But my my thing with um my thing with
Pisco was like so we were going at it about the Mum Donnie thing.
So like first of all I agree that at this point I think Jeff
should probably endorse Mum Donnie now that Eric Adams has dropped
out of the race. Um I would have to take a look at some of these
>> Yeah. I don't I think he's arguing why he wouldn't.
>> Yeah. How the He's gaslighting us. Putch is gaslighting.
I I think you can't simultaneously argue that Pisco is too much
and say that I actually agree he should endorse now. >> You
bald. You were on that podcast for how long saying no I don't
think he has to. No. What? Well, explain to me. Explain to me
if it happened in Wyoming. Well, actually, there's no way that
you thought Jeff should endorse him. >> Yeah, he was he
was totally arguing. He's arguing hard in the other direction.
Siwa, the Republican guy, says he's not dropping out and if he
stays in, I think Mom Donnie still has a pretty comfortable lead.
So, it's not like it's super urgent, but I think politically
it makes sense for Jeff to endorse number one.
>> Politically, it makes sense. Wait, >> okay. He's
gaslighting. >> So, Pisco Pisco totally won that conversation
then. >> Totally. But yeah, totally. I'm sorry. I >> He's
gaslighting. How How is he
>> He's literally giving the opposite opinion that he had
yesterday. Well, he is, but he could just be saying, "Pisco totally
convinced me." He hasn't really said Pisco hadn't convinced me
yet. If Or is he I can't tell if he's recapping his position,
cuz it seems like he's saying to me, "Okay, rewind." No, shut
up. You're not going to gaslight me, >> In case you missed,
I assume many of you guys missed it. But my thing with um >> my
thing with Pisco was like, so we were going at it about the Mum
Donnie thing. >> So, like, first of all, I agree that at
this point I think Jeff should probably endorse Mom Donnie now
that Eric Adams has dropped out of the race. Okay, that seems
like he's he's saying that was his opinion. Yeah, he's saying
at this >> but like I don't know why you'd say the thing
with Pisco is and then you say, "Oh, but at this point it's like
the thing with Pisco is Well, he did convince me." Like I don't
know. That would be a weird way to introduce this. >> if
he convinced you on everything, tell your chat to shut the [__]
up. Don't ever say anything negative about Pisco ever again.
>> I would have to take a look at some of these polls.
I know SWA, the Republican guy, says he's not dropping out and
if he stays in, I think Mom Donnie still has a pretty comfortable
lead. So, it's not like it's super urgent, but I think politically
it makes sense for Jeff to endorse number one.
>> That's like I think that was the only argument you cuz
Pisco said like morally you you should morally you absolutely
should. I don't think many people push back on that. It was more
like politically does it make sense in terms of political calculus.
So for him to go oh well even politically I think you should
that's like total capitulation to Pisco's argument as far as
I can tell. First and foremost, if Cuomo were to somehow win
that race, I think that the divisions that exist right now between
like the left and libs would be exacerbated quite a bit. So,
it's it's almost like I'm negotiating with terrorists here. That's
what it feels like. Feels like I'm negotiating with
>> Who is the terrorist? Is it Mani?
>> Hassan is the terrorist. >> No, Hassan is the
terrorist, not M. >> Why are you calling Hassan a terrorist?
He or he's asking why Hutch why is Hutch doing that. He's saying
that basically now because that's their like savior because they've
made this a like a uh what do you call it like an inflection
point because they've highlighted this now it's going to look
it's going to look like everything they say is correct if if
like there's no endorsement and then Cuomo wins they're going
to say that we totally screwed mom Donnie over and it's like
yeah because he was your candidate and Cuomo lost to him in the
in the primary and if Cuomo wins now and you don't help the candidate
who won your primary what is the point of your party what is
the point of having Democratic primary like a voted primary
if you aren't going to support the candidate who won. >> I
just think I think that's super interesting that the blue no
matter who guy get rid of the people who won't support Democrats
is for some reason using the same attack that Quomo use is using
right now against the same person. >> Oh, sure. >> Han
supports terrorists. It's like oh Mum Donnie is just out to lunch
with this like terrorist loving influencer.
>> I'm sorry Hutch. It seems like you actually are
you're kind of in line with Cuomo. Quite
>> Uh I don't even know if he'd disagree with that at this
point. >> I feel like he's uh he's pretending that he disagrees.
He's pretending that Cuomo getting in would so a lot of like
>> Um
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think the funny thing is is he's actually
conceding another argument here that he wasn't even making last
night, but I know he believes it. I've heard him say it at other
points. He thinks like the the progressives making this like
a boiling point or bring this to a boiling point like they he
thinks them and their consistent focus on Mamani as somebody
that needs to be supported. He's like, "Oh, that's really bad
strategy." And it's like I think he he thought it was like bad
strategy on their part. They were just doing something that it's
like, oh, it's just toxic. And it's like, oh, actually, you are
now totally capitulating that they owned you. Like they they
totally won in that they accomplished their goals completely.
>> He thought that they're a minority. You don't the the
small faction of people uh they need to be put in their place.
Uh most people want a moderate Dem. They don't want your extreme
leftist ideology. They don't want your socialism. And then here
they are with a popular vote and you want to pretend like they
are still just this like small pool of people that you have to
negotiate with against your will. >> Yeah. He's going to
pretend that because he's going to say it goes back to the rest
of the country where he'd say that wouldn't matter, right? which
demands that you pretend like New York City isn't like so influential
on the rest of the country. >> Well, it is influential.
I think he's uh like he would have arguments there, but I agree
with you. Maybe not necessarily. I think like the progressives
are still a pretty small wing of the party who have power in
places that like like the worst thing of ignoring progressives
in a lot of places is you just get a more moderate Democrat,
right? So, I think there's some some argument to the political
calculus, but it's getting weaker and weaker as time goes by.
And I think it's weird that he can't sense the direction things
are going. Like I think >> I think it's obvious the direction
things are going. Go ahead. >> The politics that he has
should align with a lot of the politics that they have. He just
doesn't like that. It feels like they're attacking the Democratic
party and it needs to be a coalition. And a lot of what Hassan
will say and some of the people on the left will say is that
the Democratic Party is bought. There are a lot of people in
the Democratic party who are corrupt.
They don't do what their voters are asking for. They don't do
according to the voters. They're enriching their pockets just
like the other side of the aisle. That's why it seems like everyone
gets what they want in Congress if it's moderate Dems and Conservatives.
>> Yep. Yeah. And I think that like that makes a lot of
sense is it's like don't you know that the like the positions
we're getting paid for are the ones that like everybody in middle
America wants? It's like hey guess what Trump just proved? Middle
America are morons. Okay, you can tell them what they want and
what they should want, right? You can tell them that. Now, you
don't treat them like morons. And realistically, I just mean
people are morons. It's not even about middle America. But it's
like you can push your will onto the country. You don't have
to just take opinion polls. And if you just take opinion polls,
you just try to be the most like crowdsourced put together thing.
You won't have a consistent direction. And you will get blown
the out by somebody who's Listen, Trump's got a consistent direction.
I'm going to save you. I'm going to save I am God to you guys.
That's Trump's. all like a a monument to Trump's ego. It's a
but it's a direction and people will buy in. Even if it's stupid,
people will buy into it. >> And and to me, if the thing
that makes you support some of these bot corrupt Democrats
is because they're being criticized by Hassan,
you are exactly what he's talking about when he says that liberals
are so manipulatable. Like >> spite based, >> not
even spitebased. Like I can manipulate a liberal. Republicans
can manipulate a liberal. You don't. For some reason, Hutch just
sees who is supporting Mumani
and he thinks, "Oh, this might not be good." >> Yeah. I
think he buys into like a narrative around that as well. But
it does come down to it's like ultimately about the Hassan support
and stuff,
>> Um cuz I think so this is funny cuz this will tie into
another conversation that we could have. Somebody linked me yesterday
a big thread that's basically going through Bumani's positions
and people are trying to paint him as a socialist because he
was a part of like the the DSA in in New York, right? They're
trying to paint him as a socialist, but he's like actually not
even really a socialist.
>> Is he even a democ? >> He's basically well he's
like a dem he's like more of a sock dem. Okay.
>> so we'll we'll go through this in a little bit and look
at the policies that he's actually advocating for. It's basically,
and surprise surprise, it seems to basically just come down to
his like outwardly avowedly pro Palestine position. And so they've
decided he's like a socialist. He's actually he's a total socialist
cuz he likes Palestine. It's like, oh, the rest of it is like
basically sock. >> And do you think Hutch knows like the
damage that he does in his viewers minds when he says, "I feel
like I'm negotiating with terrorists." >> When you talk
about the left of your own >> I don't think he sees it
as as damage. >> you don't think he knows that he's >> I
think he sees it as like necessary conditioning. I don't think
he sees it as damage. Yeah, >> I think there's like a political
reason why I think Jeff might endorse or why he he might should
uh endorse >> might should endorse. >> But I did
push back on peace go because I feel like the left has in they've
intentionally made this divisive. I think that's obvious. I think
that's obvious. It's not about like you. >> So, this is
what I'm I'm saying is he's he was complaining about how the
left has made it divisive and it's like >> uh the reason
they're making it divisive is because you guys will over their
candidates switching up the rules once they win. >> Yeah.
They all think the Bernie thing is real, right? That Bernie got
totally screwed. And he got screwed a little bit. He did get
screwed a little bit, but they think he got totally screwed.
If you don't endorse the candidate who won your primary and he
loses to the person who who subverted your primary process, who
joined, lost, and then tried to run anyway, if you do that, you
did [__] this guy over. You actually as a party were
like, "Yeah, this guy's like a socialist
you you can't win." You are doing the thing that I think rational
people can give you a pass on Bernie that like some things happened
there, but is mostly like, you know, individual corruption like
people who were close to the Clintons like gave interview questions
to her or something, right? But but like I don't think you get
a pass on this one. This one would just be overt. It would just
be out in the open. It would be obvious. >> Yeah. They're
like, "Oh my god, they're they're making this so divisive.
They shouldn't be able to make it divisive. You have a Democrat
who won the primary. How do you how do you let them make this
divisive? Just endorse them. Endorse the candidate for your party.
Actually look at their positions. Tell me what's wrong with them
that you would not endorse >> And then tell me why you
let him run in your primary despite having those positions. Or
did he like switch up? Did he like suddenly go, "Oh, we're going
to take like a bunch of real estate from people or something."
What did he do? >> Yeah. What did he do? You're the ones
gaslighting them in believing that no, it's fine if I'm holding
out. It's fine if I'm just like all of a sudden don't think that
this is a big deal. And maybe it's even strategic for Jeff to
not say anything yet. He's not going to have influence in his
own state. >> Okay, buddy. Uniting. It's not about the
spirit of unity. They want Mumani to be the guy who ushers in
a new kind of progressive tone for the Democratic party. They
want him to be like the air apparent to Bernie Sanders. They're
here's the thing. If the Democratic party doesn't like that,
if they're not ready for that, guess what? The the DNC primaries
are filled with progressive New York mayors who got their asses
kicked. Okay? If he is a progressive New York mayor and the Democratic
party isn't ready for that voice, he will get his ass kicked
in whatever he's doing after this, right? The people will speak.
You don't have to go and say, "Well, no, no, no. I don't want
him to win or like I don't know if you have to endorse him."
Dude, he'll just get destroyed. Like he people will reject him.
It's fine. >> You know what is manufactured though that
I didn't see any of you guys complain about? Where's that clip
of David Pacman asking that guy, "Who do you think is going to
take over for Nancy Pelosi?" Are we agreeing it's going to be
Hakee Jeff? >> Uh, I've never seen that clip. >> You've
never seen that clip? They're like, he's interviewing someone.
They're theory crafting who is the person that Nancy is going
to pass the mantle to. >> It's usually someone like >> It's
usually pretty obvious, right? Like the person who
mold them over time. I can't see him coming more out of nowhere
than AOC cuz he's about the same age as AOC as far as I know.
>> He has less popularity than AOC.
>> Yeah, sure. Oh, holy [__] Black dome crack.
For some reason, I thought he was way younger. I thought he was
like 35, >> He's 55,
>> bro. He's 55 years old. Holy [__]
>> This guy's 55.
What the [__] That's crazy. Sorry, I thought he was
way younger. I was like, "Oh, he looks older than that." But
I guess I guess whatever. They're looking for like a hostile
takeover of the party and they're demanding that national Democrats
make these endorsements because they want them to kiss the ring.
That's all this is. It's just really obvious that that's all
this is. They invented a standard. They just invented a standard
that never existed before. It was never
standard for national Democrats in the Congress to endorse mayoral
candidates.
That has never been the standard like local Democrats. Again,
I think the obvious the most obvious argument here, the easiest
argument is just, okay, in this particular case, the guy who
lost the primary is the second like is the guy who he will be
running against and you don't want to set a precedent that you're
not going to support your candidate if somebody breaks faith
with the party and runs independent after losing the primary
matter
at the local level.
So, New York assembly members that you know it's way more expected
that they do endorsements.
National Democrats like for the most part stay out of local races
even if it's a really heavily populist city like New York City.
I'm just telling you guys what the standard has always been.
There's never been there's never been this um expectation that
New York Democrats endorse someone in a new New York City mayoral
race. It just never existed before. This was never a thing. >> Schumer
endorsed Adams in 2021. I'm guessing that the New York mayor,
a lot of New York Democrats, even ones like who are uh like um
what do you call it? Federal or national senators, national congress
people, I'm guessing a lot of people step into the mayoral race
for New York and and do endorsements. Now, is it like an expected
you have to do this thing? Probably not, but I'm guessing a lot
of them do it, especially in the primary. >> Um I thought
it was telling when we've talked about this issue many >> Okay,
I'm uh I'm ending on Twitch here, guys. I'm going over to kick
only. We'll see you there in a little bit. Bye-bye. many times.
>> I'm backing this up. >> I thought it was telling
when we've talked about this issue many, many times on the stream,
but so I might be repeating myself a little bit here, but um
I thought it was telling when I asked Pisco, "So, you think that
AOC should have been expected to endorse Eric Adams in 2021?"
And he said yes. And I think he just fully debateed himself into
saying that. It's No, nobody actually believes this. >> Wait,
did he Hold on. >> He didn't debate bro himself? >> I
Wait, I'm not even sure that he said yes, you have to. What did
he say?
I feel like I feel like he might not have even said I said she
should endorse the prim the party candidate, right? >> He
would have said yes, she should have. >> I think he would
have he to be consistent, he would have to. >> He said
he would have liked him to. >> I see. I see. >> She
AOC is a she. >> Hey, Chris. No, I didn't hear that. But
also, why would I want to know about that? Get out of here. Get
out of here. >> No, but does anyone really believe this?
He said that it was wrong in retrospect that AOC didn't endorse
Eric Adams in 2021. No, nobody nobody believes this. Come on.
So, they want to pretend like it's about this new standard that
they've invented, but it's not. Like, what they want is they,
you know, they're excited about Mundan personally and they want
him to represent institutional change within the Democratic party
>> and they're counting their eggs before they've hatched.
>> They've decided that Mumani is going to be the guy,
but he's totally untested. >> Okay. Okay, so Pisco said
he basically like soft committed I guess >> institutional
change within the Democratic party and they're counting their
eggs before they've hatched. They've decided that Mumani is going
to be the guy, but he's totally untested in this kind of way.
He was a New York he was a New York assembly member. That's not
nothing, but he's like very much untested at this kind of level.
And so there's a lot of question marks around him. He has to
prove that he is a good leader and he he'll have the opportunity
to do that. And if he does, I assume he'll get more endorsements
down the road. But um >> did Eric Adams do a lot of political
leadership before he signed up? Like he was the mayor. He was
the police chief or something. >> So like I I just totally
disagree. And people endorsed Eric Adams. Chuck Schuber endorsed
Eric Adams. Like >> the standard is not just about protecting
moderates who don't want to endorse moderate national Democrats
who don't want to endorse a New York City uh mayoral candidate.
It's also about protecting people like AOC who shouldn't be who
shouldn't be forced to endorse a moderate candidate in a future
election that she doesn't like. Obvious obviously um his argument
for NYC is different. He's making this special exception because
he says that this this race has national significance. Um but
I just don't really buy that. Like you know he doesn't like Mumani
before Eric Adams dropped out. Money >> it does have Hold
on. You can't say you don't that's not like a subjective standard.
What is everybody who follows politics arguing about in terms
of dem politics? This is like a national conversation. It absolutely
is. You could say you don't like that it's been turned into one,
but it's like saying, um, you know, I don't want to talk about
the trans issue, cuz it's not really like a big conversation.
It's like, well, guess what? Republicans are saying you believe
some really crazy sh if they're going to turn if your opponent
if somebody you consider your opponent is going to focus entirely
on some specific topic, you it's you are compelled to defend
yourself or or to to have a conversation about it. Especially
when you're like, "Oh, well, this is a silly conversation to
have." Well, then you should be able to win that conversation
pretty easily. You should be able to embarrass the other person,
right? But like that's where the conversation is. It has national
intent and uh it it has national attention. You do have to treat
it as a national issue. I think was like 20 points ahead in every
poll that we saw. He doesn't need these endorsements. He literally
does not need Jeffrey's endorsements. He probably still doesn't
even need it need it now. As long as Lee was in the race, like
I don't think he needs any more endorsements. He's very comfortably
going to win. You're missing the moment, Hutch. No, no. >> So
then why is Hutch Why is Hutch saying he thinks So he just he
just argued against himself? He went, "Well, I think probably
he should endorse." And then he's like, "But here's all the reasons
that like he shouldn't endorse." Like, okay, what are the reasons
he should
>> What? Why do you believe this other than I don't want
to fight with Pisco again? >> No. Here's what's happening.
You guys want Mumani
to represent a turning point in the Democratic party. Am I wrong
about that? You guys want him to help usher in a new kind of
>> What's up? >> False. False. I don't want uh any
ushered new What I want is that Quomo does not get back control
of New York City. That the the person who used to be a Democrat
who left the Democratic party when he could not gain power,
right? when they did not let him get away with his crimes or
offenses of being a bad bot politician. What I want is for that
person to not jeopardize the Democrats ability to be mayor in
New York City. That's what I want. Why? I feel like Hutch is
making this about oh the Democratic party is changing it. That
is the Democratic candidate. I don't have another choice. I have
him or I have a corrupt dude. >> Okay. So, you're saying
Quuomo is the corrupt dude? Cuomo is the corrupt. >> For
a second, I thought you were saying that like, oh well, he's
risking like a Republican, but he's risking Cuomo. >> He's
risking Quomo, who is very close to being a Republican.
>> Uh, I don't know if I have no idea what his policies
are. I would say he's just corrupt. If you want to say that's
Republican, I wouldn't be sure if he had like some progressive
policies because he was running as a Democrat in New York. I
would assume he ran on a fairly progressive like policy agenda.
That's why I say there's a difference between a Republican up
north and a Republican in the South. Trump was a Democrat, right,
up north, Democrat in New York City. >> And Republicans
in the north could see themselves like through Trump.
>> And Cuomo is pretty up there. Like if you are a business
dude, if you make a lot of money in these cities, uh you probably
can lean you can lean Republican without without feeling like
you're socially going backwards.
>> Chris Christie was that type of um Republican. Like
he didn't I don't believe Chris Christie signed on board with
any of that like homophobic
and stuff like that. That wouldn't fly in New Jersey. >> Okay.
All right.
Um, yeah. I don't I just have to take your word for I don't even
um I don't have any experience living there. So, >> progressive
politics within the Democratic party with the progressives in
the driver seat of the party, that's what you want. You want
him to be that guy. And I'm not saying that you're wrong to want
that. That's not the point I'm making. But the reason why you're
making these demands of national Democrats who have their own
constituents that they're accountable to that may not like if
they endorse someone like Mum Donnie, to be honest with you,
I lost my train of thought there. Okay. I was like, "Dude, where
are you going?" I was so thrown off by his pause there. I'm like,
"What the just happened?" >> Oh, thank Oh, thank God he
just said something. Okay. My god. I just >> I was like
looking at his chat. I'm like, "Is he reading a chat message
or I'm like lost right now?" Jesus. >> Isn't this exactly
what made people like justify not voting for Hillary or not voting
for Kamla? You guys are trying to do something with the Democratic
party. You're like forcing like a woman onto me. You're like
forcing this DEI candidate. This isn't my Democratic party. So,
uh I really just don't care about the outcome. [__]
hap. What happened to the idea that we do need Democrats in office?
We're It's It's not an argument. There is a threat. Democracy
[__] matters. It's like Groundhog's Day with these
people. He's got the brain of a goldfish. >> Yeah. Here's
the Here's the thing. And it's So, I think this would all work.
I don't think they're quite what you see them as. I think >> who
is they? >> Um, Hutch and the other people who would argue
that Jeff doesn't have to endorse. What I think they secretly
think and don't want to say out loud. I think this is to me they're
they're doing a lie, but the lie is this. >> They're thinking
Andrew Cuomo is a Democrat. That's what they think, right? But
they don't want to say that because then they're saying and the
Andrew Cuomo is a Democrat and I secretly kind of hope he wins.
That's what they're thinking. But they don't want to say that
out loud because they know that's incredibly unpopular. So that's
what they think >> because that's that is 2016 Bernie Bros.
I'm sorry. It's this idea. No, no, no. Trump Trump was just a
Democrat. Okay. Trump was a Democrat. He saw how corrupt Hillary
was voting for Trump. That's basically voting a Democrat. I know
it sounds like I'm going against Dems, but Trump is more trustworthy
than Hillary. That they're literally repeating it. I >> they
are so shortsighted. >> I don't So maybe maybe I think
they see it as somebody who's a Democrat and not a socialist
and that he is at least aligned with them. I think that's how
they see it. I think they want Mum Donnie to not be the the mayor
there. I think they see like the Hassan sphere as like a threat
to them and they've convinced themselves it's a massive threat
and they see Mumani winning as like a huge coup for them as like
a huge success for them and they don't want that. And so they're
arguing all of these things about standards and all of this,
but what it really comes down to is they don't want Mumani to
win. They don't want to have to deal with those people like crowing
about winning, right, at all. And they're arguing a whole bunch
of stuff around the edges to try to make it seem like, well,
you know, I don't think he has to endorse and like maybe wins
at some point. >> I like completely agree with you. And
I'm just arguing against them thinking that because what you
end up doing, you end up showing that candidate. You end up showing
that candidate how much you hate your own party, how much you
cannot have disagreement within your own [__] party,
that there is power up for grabs. You create a monster. You create
an opportunity. You're not the Dems are going to try harder to
pull more mum donnies, right? And you have put a fracture
in a state where there didn't need to be one.
>> Because you kind of can't have the argument. you kind
of can't go through and weed out and put up candidates to go
against who you think shouldn't take over the party. You weren't
paying attention to New York City. You didn't care about the
indictments against Eric Adams. You were fine with the corruption
in your own party. >> I think that's the big thing is I
think that's something that like Pisco specifically is paying
attention to and he sees Hakee Jeff come out and go like, "Oh,
Eric Adams did great." And it's like this guy is corrupt and
he accepted basically like a mini pardon like has like Trump
declined to prosecute him >> for what? Why? Why did that
happen? Like what the is happening there? He's taking money from
people like >> and declined to prosecute him. When did
that come out? How soon after did Eric Adams announce that he's
dropping out? >> Yeah. I don't >> cuz people are
claiming that he got paid to drop out of the race, right? That
that gives Eric that gives
for him. Yeah. It's so brand for him to drive to go do this.
Yeah.
>> so here you have somebody who's not really paying attention
to the politics, is not looking at the mess within their own
house and is just saying, "Oh, but I kind of don't like who you
guys put up, so I'm just going to like I'm just going to be okay
with us not really doing anything and going against like the
norms or supporting our own party and hopefully things just end
up okay." >> I know what I was talking about, but I can't
remember what that how that last thing tied to the thing that
I was talking about. No, but that that's what you guys want him
to be that guy and maybe he maybe he'll be one of those guys,
you know, maybe the party is moving in a more, you know, pop
populist progressive kind of direction and maybe he's one of
these guys that's like changing the party, but you've already
decided in your minds that he's the guy and uh you're skipping
the part where he earns the endorsements from national Democrats.
Like an endorsement from a national Democrat, that's something
that you have to earn. That's not something that you should that
you're going to get for free. You have to earn that through like
good leadership. and he hasn't had any time to earn that yet.
Like he's just this unt they don't know anything about this guy.
Like why? Like they don't How much did you guys even know about
this guy? Like before like four months ago. Isn't Mumani in favor
of rent control? That's wildly unpopular. I don't even know if
rent control is unpopular. It's just bad policy. It's just bad
policy. Like we we know that at this point we have so many data
sets to point to. It's just objectively bad policy. But I I think
it might actually technically be popular. NYC Dems on the other
hand should make their positions known. I I I agree with that.
like there should be way more pressure on local Democrats and
state level Democrats
to weigh in on this mayor's race. And I think it's politically
advantageous because at a time when the Democrats have a major
branding problem, I think having Cuomo be the mayor um of New
York City would be uh would would only continue to hurt the Democratic
party brand. And so I think we should, you know, do what we can
to make sure that that outcome doesn't happen. But why should
why should a like why should a more moderate New York Democrat
be expected to endorse a straightup
socialist mayoral candidate? Why would that standard ever be
that standard is never going to happen? The standard is never
going to happen in a Pisco already argued he wasn't trying to
make it a standard. He said it was just about New York City.
He literally said that. And Hutch is going to go back to the
point that he like he has like a total straw man point that he
can argue against and he he's just going to keep rolling back
there because Pisco isn't here right now. In >> a million
years this is not going to happen. And I felt like Pisco
by deflecting to Kamala. I think he was just wildly dismissing
the difference between a presidential race and a mayoral race.
the expectations for endorsements when it comes to presidential
candidates. That's a totally different calculation.
When there's only one person at the top and you either get the
Republican or you get the Democrat and that person is going to
run the entire country. They're going to run the executive branch
of the entire country. At that point, the the pressure for endorsements
flows down to everybody below Kamla. Everybody below the candidate
should get behind the Democratic nominee in a presidential race.
In a New York City mayoral race where it's not even a particularly
close race. This isn't about like protecting Mandani from GOP
attacks. This isn't about like uniting the party. They're these
people are intentionally making this a divisive issue. They're
picking this fight. They are picking the fight. You expected
socialists to endorse a moderate. Why would it not go the other
way? My standard applies consistently, consistently. This is
not the same thing as the Kla race. It's it's not the same thing.
It's a totally totally different scenario. Completely different
scenario. I would be saying the same thing if the dynamic was
flipped. If this was a moderate NYC mayoral candidate who was
running against a scandal plagued
uh incumbent or
a and a different challenger. So like instead of Eric Adams and
Cuomo being more moderate, like let's imagine they're super leftist.
The numbers are all the same. Okay? And then let's say Mani is
a moderate and Mani is just dominating in that race. I would
not sit here and tell you that I think AOC should be obligated
to endorse uh the moderate mom Donnie and neither would you.
You would not be saying this. You wouldn't be saying this last
night. You were not consistent with your judgment of people not
endorsing Kamla. I don't care that Mdani didn't endorse Kamla
because who like nobody knew who that guy was. He was totally
irrelevant. I don't care. Of course, he should uh he should endorse
Kamla in that spot obviously.
Obviously. But I just don't care because nobody knew who he was.
With Hassan, like way more people knew knew who Hassan was, you
know, nine months ago or 10 months ago than people knew who Mandi
was. We've been I feel like we've been round and round on this
like a thousand times, you guys. I like this is this is one of
the things that makes me like a little bit blackpilled about
the progressive movement right now. I'm so blackpilled when it
comes to progressives right now because it seems like the consistent
attitude that I see so often is they think that power should
just be given to them. That's what I'm seeing. They just think
they just think people should just give them power. Like before,
like before they've even gone through the the work of convincing
voters to give them power. Like the voters are the ones that
will give you power. If you want that power, you're going to
have to earn that from the voters. That's how
>> uh what does he think mom Donnie did? >> This
is going to go down. Why haven't you endorsed the New York candidate
for park district commissioner? Yeah. Yeah. Super chats. I I'm
sorry. Yes. Thank you. All elite memes. Thank you so much for
$10. He wants to put his name on it so that if it's good, people
know he did it. If it's bad and Dems try to reverse it, he can
just write it off as TDS. It's the reverse reason Republicans
call ACA Obamacare. The Trump RX thing. If they make a platform
called >> rest of the stream is going to be JTO DMing Cherry
and not commenting on the video. Uh yeah, I'm trying to have
a conversation off stream to fix things. Yeah, obviously great
great insight. >> A platform called Trump RX where people
are going to trump.org or whatever to buy their drugs. Um that
might pay off if there are some price reductions in the beginning.
But what what happens if >> it's hard to watch? No, it's
not. I guarantee you if I open up I'm not even looking at what
the viewership is. I guarantee if I open up the stream uh viewership
will have spiked because people think we're fighting because
that's literally what people try to show up for. I know exactly.
Don't say it's hard to watch. I know it's not hard to watch.
Prices go up. Again, it's just a really kind of short-sighted
view. I think that's a very risky strategy. You know, I guess
you could just abandon the name Trump RX and just name it something
else. Um
JDub's with $2. Why Why are you talking over the audio? But pause
it. I gotta be better at that. Especially if I can't get the
ducking thing to work. I don't know why it's not working. Um,
bad company with $5. I don't know if it was brought up, but your
mic was cutting out bad when you and Pisco were going at it.
Was it? Uh, how? >> Wait, what? >> I Why it's not
working. Um, Bad Company with $5. I don't know if it was brought
up, but your mic was cutting out bad when you and Pisco were
going at it. Was >> I didn't hear this happen at all. >> Uh,
how to do it with 53 months. Thank you so much, buddy. Ake with
$20.
Feel like Pisco shouldn't be hostile debating on live and learn.
doesn't fit the venue. Also, it's kind of weird he ends with,
"Touch my bro." Like, are you supposed to ignore the last 20
minutes of aggression yelling? Two. So, in Pisco's defense, I
can compartmentalize. >> I You're not going to fool me.
>> Um I appreciate a spirited debate because even though
we disagreed on a lot of stuff, it never really got like um like
we weren't really like it was a different kind of argument that
I than compared with the ones that I've had with like black people
lefties or MAGA people where we're like really yelling at each
other and we're going at it. But when that conversation stops,
I don't feel like any animosity. I don't like some of his arguments.
I think some of his arguments were really or listen, I thought
his arguments were very flawed. But I mean, to your point, like
I feel like he doesn't need to say that. I agree with you. Like
he doesn't he doesn't need to say like, "Oh, you're my boy."
Like I don't need that disclaimer. It's fine.
>> I'm not a I know we're friends. You don't have to keep
saying it over and over again. >> Um bad company with $5.
K's and Doobie fried his brain. Bro claimed mom Donnie is the
base. Oh, prime Kais. You mean that guy? And Doobie? >> Oh
my goodness. Doobie is so powerful. Dubbie spends like two hours
online. Sorry. Dubie spends like four hours talking to streamers
like a week and apparently he convinces everybody of
>> Claim to mom Donnie is the base. That's just, you know,
like that I like you hear it so often, right? Um the way that
leftists talk about themselves and their candidates. Um they
describe themselves as the base. Oh, you're ignoring the base.
Like, there's this exciting new grassroots energy with this candidate.
And because Jeffre refuses to endorse, that means he's ignoring
the base. God, could you imagine if you could go back and find
Hutch's like Bernie Sanders stuff, like his uh his excitement
around Bernie Sanders and just like show his old past self to
himself and just go like this is what people are talking about.
This kind of like energy. >> And it's like the base. What
do we What? How did you How did you tie Mum Donnie with like
the median Democratic voter? That's just simply not true. I feel
like you're the one ignoring the base by demanding that, you
know, more moderate Democrats endorse a guy who said that the
end goal is to seize the means of production. You know, like
again, I'd be happy to vote for MD in New York City. >> wait.
Is that a quote from
is that a quote from Mumdani that we need to like seize the means
of production or what is he even saying there? >> You know,
more moderate Democrats endorse a guy who said that the end goal
is to seize the means of production. You know, like again, I'd
be happy to vote >> Hold on. Let's look that up. I'm going
to look that up in New York City. Um it seems like um he he impressed
me greatly with his campaign and he's impressed me even more
since he won the nomination. Okay, one second. Let's see what
this is about. Politact in context, Zoron's Zoran Mani's use
of the phrase seizing the means of production. What's it mean?
A phrase Zoran Mani used in 2021 made the rounds in media reports
and social media after the 33-year-old won the Democratic primary
in the New York City mayor mayoral race. A self-described democratic
socialist, Mamani used the phrase seizing the means of production
during a live stream conference of the young democratic socialists
of America in February 2021. A White House spokesperson highlighted
Mdani's use of the phrase in an email to Politifact July 1st,
days after we published our July June 26th uh fact check of President
Donald Trump, who called Mandani communist in a truth social
post. The White House didn't send us evidence to support Trump's
statement before our fact check was posted. Multiple political
scientists and communism experts told us Mandani's mayoral race
positions did not amount to communism. We rated a Trump statement
false. The spokesman sent us a June 30th New York Post article
highlighting Mandani's 2021 remarks as a newly elected state
assemblyman and a 2020 Mumani tweet praising a young leader.
We won't dwell on this po on the latter post because Mamani's
point isn't clear. Oh well, that's not going to load because
it's an archive thing. Fox News mediite and CNN pundits flagged
his resurface remarks. After reviewing the tape and reinterviewing
experts, we decided not to change our false rating. Mamani's
views in the mayoral race do not reflect communism and experts
found his 2021 remark too brief to reach detailed conclusions.
What he said about a month after taking office in 2021, Mdani
spoke at a spoke to a young Democratic socialist of America virtual
conference. Throughout the this roughly 40-minute remarks or
throughout his roughly 40-minute remarks, Mdani praised Democratic
socialism. The relevant portion of this clip starts around minute
10 uh when he spoke about acting on an agenda based on conviction
of his beliefs whether they are popular or not. But then there
are also issues that we firmly believe in whether it's BDS
uh right or whether it's BDS right or whether it's the end goal
of seizing the means of production where we do not have the same
level of support at this very moment. And what I want to say
is that that it is critical that we that the way we organize
that the way we set up our no or you know set up our work and
our priorities that we do not leave any one issue for the other
that we do not meet a moment and only look at what people are
ready for that we do not meet a moment and only look at what
people are ready for but we are doing both of these things in
tandem because it is critical for us to both meet people where
they are or where they're at and to also organize and organize
for what is correct and for what is and to ensure over time that
we can bring people to that issue. So, this is saying you need
to like be able to identify where people are, not advocate for
crazy, but also try to push the the political movement you're
behind in a direction that you feel like is moral. That's literally
every politician does this, right? So, he's saying we are socialist.
We do believe in pushing in that direction. It doesn't talk about
the velocity. And that really is what the issue is is you can
be a democratic socialist, which he is at the democratic socialists
of America, right? You can believe you can push towards socialism
democratically. Foundational to democratic socialism is that
you get there through the ballot box and not through seizing
the means of production violently. It seems pretty obvious. Okay,
continuing. Like he's doing the things that you should be doing.
Like he is
exercising it seems like a great deal of pragmatism and that
to me is my most important thing. Like if I see somebody being
pragmatic then I have way more trust for them. Even if they're
like really ideologically different from me, if they show that
they're pragmatic,
then we can get past those ideological differences because they
matter just so much less because you know what does it matter
if you're ideologically a socialist if you understand that you're
not going to be able to do socialism as the mayor of New York
City then and you have to work within the constraints of like
the system. Aiden with $5 peace go bots are going crazy in chat
right now. I just it's so clear to me what is going on, you know?
It's so clear to me what is going on. It is >> Oh, please
elucidate. Please make it clear to us what is going on. But the
end goal is still seizing the means of production. No. Even if
democratically, you could say that black ice, but that is also
saying you you your primary goal is following the will of the
people, right? Convincing people of your way of thinking. It
doesn't mean that you're so the people people's problem with
socialism usually is that it's it requires like total authoritarian
control to enact. That's usually their problem. moving in like
a a democratic socialist direction or being a sock dem like moving
through this progression of of beliefs is not necessarily bad
under anybody's interpretation of the world just this it's this
invented standard how like hold on to the people >> he's
just fighting this he's going to fight the strong >> disagree
with me okay >> do you acknowledge that this standard never
existed before Mumonni do you acknowledge that it was never actually
a thing that New York's national democrats were expected to endorse
mayoral candidates. This was >> okay. But this is not a
standard situation, so you shouldn't even be talking about a
standard. How about the standard is when the fascist leader of
the Republican party is basically endorsing the guy who lost
your primary and that guy is his biggest competition, then obviously
you fall in line behind your candidate.
That that is the situation. Don't invent some standard argument
that you want to have. Don't do any of that. Focus on Eric Adams
took a bribe to drop out or very likely, you know, I think we
could all believe he took a bribe to drop out and focus on the
fact that Trump's offering it to him. Trump is not prosecuting
him for his corruption before. Like, focus on these things. Focus
on the situation at hand. It's never a thing. This has never
been a standard. Do you guys acknowledge that this is just a
new invented >> I I actually I'm going to go back during
this and just look at the chat and see arguing this. National
Democrats
>> have we ever cared about >> expected to endorse
mayoral candidates? This was never a thing. >> I don't
know how a minority can control. >> has never been a standard.
Do you guys acknowledge that this is just a new invented standard?
>> Delasio was endorsed. You're just ignoring his popularity.
I think uh sure a good chunk of Dems that don't know him, but
more do than don't. And it is magnitudes more that approve than
disapprove.
I don't even know if that's >> There wasn't a vote blue
no matter who expectation until recently. Also, I >> What's
the cause of the blue no matter who expectation? What is the
cause of that? What is the underlying thing that has moved people
in that direction to advocate for that as a policy? >> I
think that's true. I think vote vote blue no matter who I feel
like has been a thing for a really long time. Hang on a second.
Let me look into this. I mean, like we're when we're talking
about um electoral strategy, why would you not why would you
not vote blue? Like what why would you why would you do why would
you take any step in any race and any district or state across
the country? Why would you take a step as a voter that would
allow a Republican to sit in that seat? Unless we're talking
about really extraordinary circumstances where the Republican
is like, you know, pretty reasonable and has really good policies
and the Democrat was just awful. Like, why would you why would
you ever ever as a voter take any kind of risk that would result
in a Republican sitting in that chair? How long has voting blue
no matter who been a slogan? I feel like that probably goes back
decades, right? The phrase is relatively
recent, but the sentiment has been a thing for a little bit longer.
A lot longer. Um, we could honestly we could just we could just
change that phrase. >> He's so close to thinking about
it. He's so close to thinking about it right now. >> Just
be vote blue, you know, like do I care about standards? This
is a party at an all-time low approval fighting off a fascistic
admin. Why am I now looking at why why am I looking at standard
and traditions right now? The only reason I bring that up is
because the people that have been >> Oh, that person gets
it. critical of National Democrats for not endorsing have been
pretending as though this is a standard that they're violating.
Like they're breaking precedent because this young exciting progressive
guy, they're threatened by him. So they're breaking precedent
by not endorsing. That's their framing. They're framing it that
way. I didn't frame it that way. They invent
here. Hold on. I'm pulling it back just a little bit here. Give
me one second. Watch uh watch Rob's media. I'm putting you guys
in hell for like uh a quick minute here. Okay. Is watching Rob's
media? Give me two seconds. I'll be right back. By this point
in her career, Casey Tron had decided to drop her old boobby
streamer character and act more like herself. However, this strategy
didn't work and many found her actual self to be more obnoxious
and petty than her old persona. She has a pattern of getting
into drama of random streamers, demonizing them to her audience,
and then playing victim once she gets called out on her. It's
truly pathetic, and there's multiple examples of her doing this.
First is her long-standing drama of XQC, which started in April
2023. XQC had reacted to the then recent Steven Crowder video,
which shows Crowder verbally abusing his pregnant wife. As you'd
expect, XQC gives a terrible take, comparing this to the illegal
battle he had to deal with involving his exartner, Adept. She
falsely claimed the two were in a common law marriage and alleged
that XQC physically abused her. This was later disproved in court.
And if you want a more detailed look into the situation, go watch
this video by Jabron, link down below. Hassan called out XQC
for comparing the two situations as Crowers was objectively worse
even before more information came out against him. One time in
his life, he shouldn't just like immediately think, "Oh, my situation
is similar to this." It's not. Shut the [__] up.
Literally, shut the [__] up, Andy. Okay, I'm not
your lawyer, but like you have been shutting the [__]
up so far, which is the right thing to do. That's why it's an
entirely different situation. It's an entirely different [__]
context. Just just keep shutting the [__] up about
your thing and don't lead anyone to think that your thing is
similar to his thing, okay? Cuz it's not. What the [__]
is wrong with you? And Assan is correct here. However, Casey
disagreed as she then went on Assange's Discord to rant about
how terrible he was to XQC. She does not think XQC is a straightup
abuser, but does interpret his takes as a massive red flag. She
also later called him a manipulator, implying that he's abusive.
She also ties him back to Destiny in order to poison the well.
She would do the same to Chloic after he read the messages on
stream, referring to him as a Destiny orbiter. This drama boils
down to one ignorant person saying something stupid to another
ignorant person who says something stupid. Though, at least if
XQC, there's an excuse for why he's so dumb. He's French Canadian.
>> Sparky's favorite snack is red if girl is from >> Apple.
Apple. >> What's Sparky's favorite snack?
>> Apples. Yeah. >> Yeah, I got it. Casey would continue
spuring out on Twitter, even liking a tweet from this communist
bed blob that wish Logic's gruesome demise. liked by Casey Trron.
So Casey Tron clearly agrees. Bear in mind at this point up until
now I've not said to my knowledge anything particularly egregious
about Casey Tron. I've not had a go at her weight or the way
she looks or anything. I don't think the worst I've said is that
she's like crazy or insane maybe for saying this stuff. That's
like the worst I've said to my knowledge. >> All this really
did for Casey was create enemies out of XQC and Ch Logic who
from this point on would mock her for looking like a meat Canyon
cartoon. >> Why would I show this picture? What do you
mean? This is her in a Barbie picture. She was look she looks
fantastic. What do you mean? Barbie girl in a Barbie world. Come
on, stop it. No, don't be misogynistic. Come on. I'm trying to
be nice. I'm trying to be nice. Casey would further attach herself
to a son pecker's community following this. As she needed a group
of people to fall back on when she got hate, she began using
the Israel Palestine movement to farm easy likes on Twitter,
going after Asmin Gold when he called out protesters who were
unlawfully blocking roads. Casey Tron would respond by mocking
his uncleanliness. As Asmin lives like a hoarding cave troll,
his bedroom is like walking into a house at Halloween Horror
Nights. Asmin is pretty used to these jokes by now, so he called
her out on her own lifestyle. You're fat and you spend your life
smoking weed and doing drugs. If anyone's a stinker, it's you.
What really ramped up the drama is when people found this tweet.
Thankfully, XQC's lifestyle hasn't led indirectly to the death
of one of his parents yet. So, he has that going for him over
Asmin at least. Casey Tron had liked that tweet, something she
owned up to on stream. >> I'll admit, I did like that tweet,
and I I have a lack of respect for Asmin Gold after letting his
mom with COPD live in those sort of conditions. I'm sorry. Like,
you're a millionaire. You have all of the resources in the world.
Why is your sick mother living like that? Like, I'll say it.
I don't care if that makes me a bad person. Still miles above
Asmin Gold. The double down is why I find her liking that tweet
to be horrendous. She genuinely believes Asmin has something
to do with his mother's death without knowing the ins and outs
of that situation. There's no proof of Asmin neglecting his mom.
Casey just thinks this because she suffered from COPD and assumes
Asmin didn't take good enough care of her. >> He had money
to do something about it and he chose not to. And I just don't
have any respect for him or that, right? It's until the facts
contradict his life choices. Then it's then it's what about compassion?
What about empathy? She tripled down in November 2024, tweeting,
"I think a great sin is being a millionaire and letting your
sick mother live an absolute filth without even lifting a finger
or using any of your endless resources to do anything about it.
So awful." A ton of other creators ambassadored her for this,
including XQC, who called out her hypocrisy and shaming Asmin's
lifestyle. She responded back by claiming he abuses Adderall.
And to be fair, he does take Adderall for his ADHD, but I haven't
seen any proof of him abusing it. Honestly, I think Casey needs
to get back on Adderall so she can stop spazzing out on Twitter.
Casey would actually get banned from Twitch on May 2nd, which
many assumed was in relation to the comments about Asmin Gold's
mother. It was actually for a different reason, though we'll
get into that shortly. She would use the situation to play victim
while also advocating for her critics to get banned from Twitch.
>> I've had the policy of not ever like responding back
to people or saying things that are like uh mean back to people.
We are getting rid of that policy. I'm bored of of sitting here
and being a punching bag, especially by clowns like this. >> This
is like very much so Asmin Gold telling his community to harass
me. And this was live on Twitch whenever he said it, which is
against the toos. Um, but it was basically him vague signaling
his viewers to harass me and I think is probably why the brigading
and whatnot has been so bad. >> Casey, he's saying it's
justified to attack you after you attacked him first. He's not
summoning his horde of to go after you. He's explaining why it's
okay to criticize your actions cuz the reality of the situation
is she can't take accountability for her actions. She'll instead
deflect and place the blame on her so-called incel haters. Make
fun of her drug problems, you're an incel. Call her out on being
a crybully, you're an incel. Mock her appearance, you're an incel.
And also, it's like even in this picture, it's like they just
look like incelss because really I feel like I'm a pretty averagesized
woman, you know? I will say I have gained a little bit of weight
cuz I got off of Adderall. Like that's really me over. It's so
misogynistic is really all it is. It's just always the default
for misogynistic dumb men. >> And yes, she is indeed watching
Turkish Thomas and I'm sorry to say, but she completely owns
him. >> Look, Casey Tron, I love you so much, okay? I'm
your biggest fan. I've been watching you since day one. However,
>> okay, well, how tall is this guy? How tall is this guy?
No way this guy is over 5'8. I would say he's probably my height.
Yeah, I would say he's 5' 3, >> Almost every tweet she
has made these past couple of years is calling someone an incel.
This might have been funny at first, but got old fast since the
joke has grown stale. She feels the need to reply to random [__]
who make weed jokes, as if this will actually change anything.
And I'm sure there are some terminally online involuntary celibates
who [__] on her. But most are just people mocking
her for being a middle-aged woman who spends all day getting
high while half paying attention to whatever she's watching.
Even if you have a girlfriend, you're still being called an incel.
She's gone mad. She sees these supreme gentlemen everywhere.
It's such an injustice. I don't understand you girls. >> And
the biggest kicker is she's best friends of one of the biggest
incels on the internet. Mike from PA. >> Hey babe, watch
this. >> I think that's fine. So, a guy pays for my cab.
>> I didn't.
Hello. I'm back. Hello. Hello. Hello. Sorry. I'm going to go
back to the Hutch thing now. We're back. >> As a voter,
take any kind of risk that would result in a Republican sitting
in that chair. How long has voting blue no matter who been a
Logan? I feel like that probably goes back decades, right? The
phrase is relatively
recent, but the sentiment has been a
>> So, we went through Hutch, not remembering where Blue,
no matter who comes from. >> Um, do I care about standards?
This is a party at an all-time low approval fighting off a fascistic
admin. Why am I now looking at why why am I looking at standard
and traditions right now? The only reason I bring that up is
because the people that have been critical of National Democrats
for not endorsing have been pretending as though this is a standard
that they're violating. Like they're breaking precedent because
this young exciting progressive guy they're threatened by him.
So they're breaking precedent by not endorsing. That's their
framing. They're framing it that way. I didn't frame it that
way. They invented the stand. >> I don't know. So are all
leftists like do they not understand like what the actual arguments
would be? I don't see it that way. I don't think so. I think
a lot of people who lean left in my chat have known these arguments.
So, it seems odd to me that he doesn't understand the arguments.
He's just arguing against the straw man. That the argument should
never be, well, this is the standard, right? You could argue,
oh, it's like blue no matter who. But to me, it's like, yeah,
it's blue no matter who because Trump is pushing the other guy.
You have like the other party putting their finger on the scale
to help a candidate who lost your primary. So, if you want if
you want party loyalty to mean anything, it probably means standing
behind this guy right now. probably the most important time.
>> This was not a thing ever before this. I think that
the idea that this election matters is a salient point, not whether
or not national New York national dems need to endorse a New
York mayoral candidate. I mean, I have a hard time with that
argument. I have a hard time with that argument because I assume
a lot of the people that are making that argument now were singing
a very different tune in November. like the Kla Trump election
was literally uh 10,000 times more important than this mayoral
race and a lot of the people who refused to uh you know like
firmly back the candidate back then are now trying to impose
this new standard now. People who demand Mumani endorsement don't
actually care about fascism rising. They say they do, but they
don't. All they want is power. Fascists by any other political
color. I wouldn't call these people fascists. I just think they're
I think that's what's going on. I'm trying I'm trying to like
I'm trying to just like neutally observe that anger and not react
to it as much. Uh but the fact of the matter is is that the left
flank of this party there they're really they feel like they've
had the answers to deliver us from Trump for decades. They feel
like they've been ignored. They feel like they've been passed
up. They feel like they've been disrespected. And in many cases
they're not even wrong. Um I don't even disagree that some Democrats
have shhat all over the left >> Yeah.
Really?
Who like who Hutch? I I mean I would like to focus on influencers
first. Could we focus on influencers first? Like who who precisely
has shot on the left flank of the party? >> Um in some
cases, right? But like but they they feel like they could have
they could have been the ones to stop to stop Trump were were
it not for those pesky moderates and
uh right-wing Democrats. They like to call anybody to their right
like right-wing, you know. So they call like uh they call people
like Spanberger and uh who's that? Who's that? Senator Slotkin.
They call they call politicians like those right-wing Democrats.
And so they they feel like the right-wing Democrats have blocked
them from getting power and are truly the ones to blame for the
rise of Trump. Oh, Neo. No, no, no, no. Neoc, this is like the
totally wrong position to have.
The the So you don't want the Dems to support a guy. You want
the Dems. Okay. The Dems decided we're going to have a vote on
who our candidate is going to be for the party. The Dems or sorry
the the Dem voters chose Zora Mam Donnie. Okay. You do not want
to let
Cuomo go in the race, not support mom Donnie, and totally undo
the will of your voters. As long as the second most popular person
in this mayoral race is Cuomo, you should support Manny so as
not to subvert your own primary process. That's like a harsh
requirement. Otherwise, you have like a whole section of your
party that is not going to trust like the uh what would you call
like the corporate Democrats is not going to trust the mainstream
of the party to to ever like respect another coalition, right?
Hence the flowchart logic. That's like that's at the that's at
the very top of the flowchart logic. That's what all that springs
from is this fundamental belief that they have the tools to beat
Trump and to beat Republicans and to deliver Democrats like enormous
supermajorities that will be lasting for decades. you know, they
really really truly in their heart believe this and uh there's
a lot of problems with that logic and so it's like fruit of the
poison tree because everything springs from that logic. There's
just a lot of bad ideas that get thrown around. Everyone is not
just the left. You need to stop this weird crusade you have against
the dudes on the same side. I think you got a lot more stubbornness
in you than you're willing to admit. I'm almost ready to like
time you out for a week for saying
>> Dude, hold on. I have to read that. Uh,
dude, everyone is not just the left. You need to stop this weird
crusade you have against the dudes on the same side. I think
you got a lot more stubbornness in you than your Oh boy. Listen.
Oh boy. They got him. Critical hit right there. >> Ideas
that get thrown around. Everyone is not just the left. You need
to stop this weird crusade you have against the dudes on the
same side. I think you got a lot more stubbornness in you than
you're willing to admit. I'm almost ready to like time you out
for a week for saying that. Wait, why do I know AC real? Why
do I know that guy? I feel like I should know that guy from Twitter.
Is that guy like big on Twitter or something? I feel like Do
I know that guy from something? No. Why do I know that name?
Resi Chatter. Oh, I could have sworn that was like maybe I've
seen him in my chat before or something. Hold on. Let me see
if I like know the name. I would have thought I knew it from
uh from Twitter or something. Oh, he types in here. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. He's typed in here before. Never mind. Got it. Does where
is this energy for the people on the left flank? >> I just
I just looked up this audio. Give me a second.
>> Where is this energy for the people on the left flank
that spend 90% of their time on Democrats and over 50% of the
time they on Republicans, they tie it back to on Democrats. And
so if I complain about those people, that's a problem. But there's
no smoke for those >> I just I think you could only do
this if you live in clips, right? Like nobody could really have
this opinion of even some of the more unhinged people in the
Hassan adjacent space, the Twitch poll space, unless they just
only watch clips. Like I got to imagine Hassan's watching the
news all day. I can't imagine 90% of his coverage of Democrats
is just on them. I just can't see it. >> People spending
all their time focused in the wrong direction. That's frustrating
to read that. It's okay to be I just don't like dishonesty and
I don't like intellectual.
>> See, teeny tiny Tony, I also think this is probably
not true, right? that they spend all of their time starking on
Hassan. They probably spend a substantial amount of time doing
it enough that it's like of note, but I just don't see it being
like most of the time, a ton of their time, right? There are
some some like characterizations of how much time they spend.
Most, not even most. It's not most. Come on, man. For none of
those guys is most, right? All of these people have actual political
opinions. They actually watch the news. They can't tie it to
somebody else, right? They can't they just can't they don't they
don't go they don't stream long enough to do it. They don't stream
short enough to do it. So, but I think it's it's probably like
more time than you'd expect and that it's like a focus. Like
they know, listen, for all of them, okay, for for Loerbox, for
Destiny, for Hutch, for for these people, snarking on Hassan
is a pleasure, okay? And for for some of the other people, like
snarking on those guys is a pleasure, okay? Destiny has I understand
that Destiny is obsessed with Hassan. You think I'm defending
him from that? I'm not. I'm just saying that it's not like most
of his content. It's probably one of his most popular topics.
It's just it's like uh it's like hyperbole that doesn't need
to be done. But what it's it's fine. That's why I'm just saying
I I really doubt Hassan is is on Democrats Democrats all the
time. I feel like this is extreme hyperbole from Hutch going
back in the other direction. I think there's way too much focus
on like the the bad clips that you want to disassociate from
people for. And it's not looking at like the broad base of who
they are, what they advocate for. It's not looking at the the
actual political positions to come to this decision, right? It's
like looking you saw him do this with Manny, right? He's like,
"Well, I don't know if we should be associated with somebody
who talked about seizing the means of production." And it's like,
"Oh, so one clip from 2021 is enough for you to go, oh, well,
got to write that guy off." It's just a stupid way to engage
in my opinion. So, I'm calling Hutch out for it, but we should
probably keep a, you know, uniform standard >> laziness.
Hutch, don't punch left. Let us talk. Let us talk about you,
but to attack me, but don't attack me back, I assume, is what
this saying. Dude, his his chat's going to fire him up into like
a rage, right? This is just going to turn into like he's going
to start asking for Hassan clips. Show me the Show me Hassan
celebrating terrorists again. I feel like I could see where it's
going. >> This ties into the whole theory of punching left,
which is one of the most ridiculous things that I've ever heard
in my life. The concept of or the proposition that punching left
should be taboo is ridiculous. It's absurd. >> What was
he saying about people on the left? I Okay, >> think about
think about what you're saying. I'm sorry. I know I'm repeating
myself cuz I know I've said this a thousand times. Think about
what you're proposing with this whole like don't punch left thing.
Really think about it for a second. >> See, speaking of
people who spend all of their time doing things, okay, we address
a teeny tiny Tony chat message.
>> no, I've said this a thousand times. >> Speak
of the devil. He shall appear. Okay, this guy's This guy's snarking
like crazy in other places. Look at this. These people aren't
Mum Donnie. It feels like you associate M Donnie with all the
most extreme and aggressive snarkle lefties online. Guys all
over the place. >> About what you're proposing with this
whole like don't punch left thing. M really think about it for
a second cuz what you're saying in effect is that
uh nobody to the to the right even 1%
nobody to the right of like the online left should ever criticize
them. That's what you're saying. That's what you're >> Um
so what is Josiah's philosophy pondering politics is like well
I'm not going to do that because it's just not going to be helpful,
right? It's like not going to be helpful. Um, it's way more helpful
for me to spend, you know, one hour I could spend on Hassan.
I could spend that hour on Trump and I'm going to do that all
the time, right? Uh, there's there's probably something to policing
like everybody around you, including people on the left. There's
probably something acceptable there. I think once you start talking
about taking like large swaths of people and cutting them off
from your party entirely, I think that's where it turns into
a different conversation where you like shouldn't be Listen,
you can do you can punch left, but you shouldn't be doing like
uh you shouldn't be doing like pulling out your bone saw on the
left, okay, to your left. You should probably keep the bone saw
in the bag and you throw a couple jabs once in a while and then
that's probably a more reasonable approach, right? That's all.
If those people are spending a lot of their time and we we watched
that video, Conduit's video where he watched all of Hassan's
streams for a week straight. So, we saw what he was doing. He
was doing flowchart [__] the whole time, bro. He
was going way harder on Democrats than he was Republicans. Like,
we saw it. We saw it. >> Wait, is he There's no way.
I I must have just hallucinated cuz I could have sworn he said
blow charge. Connor was doing Did he say Connor? There's no way
Hutch is a sincere fan of Counterpoints's flowchart streams.
I did not just hear that. I It was a different name, right? I
misunderstood. >> If those people are spending a lot of
their time and we watched that video, Conduit's video where he
watched all >> Oh, never mind. Conduit. Conduit. Conduit.
Conduit. I knew it couldn't be. I thought he was saying Connor
for a second. I was going to lose. I was like, there's no way.
There's no possible way he's saying he enjoys the Connor flowchart
streams. And sure >> of Hassan streams for a week straight.
So we saw what he was doing. He was doing flowchart [__]
the whole time,